- All right everybody.
I always end this show with a
fun story from the internet.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(playful music)
(cheers)
When it comes to the eating
habits of college kids,
You probably picture late
night pizza and Top Ramen.
I doubt a home cooked meal
ever enters the picture.
But that is not the case
at Kansas State University.
Y'all a group of students have opened
their own home cooked pasta business
for just five bucks.
You get a heaping to-go box
of delicious homemade pasta
served right out their kitchen
window, which is incredible.
They even make dessert
'cause they're awesome.
It has students lining
up around the block.
Let's get these pasta
entrepreneurs in here.
Everybody say hello
to Santino, Quinn, Kennedy and Tyler
watching on Kansas teen topica.
What's up y'all?
- Not too much We're
just excited to be here.
- I am- I love this story so much.
So I mean, I feel like
usually college kids
are just grabbing stuff
and not actually cooking ever.
So Santino and Quinn, where
did you even get this idea?
Where'd it come from?
- Yeah, so it goes way
back to my hometown in KC.
I got a Sicilian family
and of course I'm going to
know how to cook pasta one of these days.
So we always had Pasta
Sundays back at home
and as soon as we moved
to college I decided,
hey, I want to continue
the Pasta Sunday tradition.
And I continued to make the sauce
and serve my friends and they've loved it.
- Yeah. Yes we have
- Yes. And it got to
the point where people
random people on campus
were just noticing us
and calling us the pasta boys.
So that's when we decided
to expand our operation
a little bit.
Now, a few Sundays every month
we have our Pasta Sundays
serve hundreds of people every time.
And we just kind of
serve until we run out.
- Yeah.
- It can get kind of chaotic,
but it's a lot of fun.
- It's so fun, yeah.
- It's incredibly cool.
So Kennedy and Tyler, who does what?
- So we really all just play
off of our own strengths.
So Tino's obviously the
mastermind behind the whole thing.
He cooks all the pasta.
- The only Italian.
- Yeah. And Tyler's the money guy.
He handles all the money.
And then we've got Quinn over here
who boxes and preps all the orders,
hands 'em out the window
with smiling face.
And I'm the social media
and marketing manager.
I'm a student at the School
of Medias and Communication
here at K State.
And I really know the power of like
getting a message out onto
social media platforms.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I just knew
that our community needed to
know what these guys were doing
and it's been crazy turning them
into overnight internet
sensations from this.
- Yes.
- And nothing would've been possible.
without the help of Kennedy.
She makes us look a lot better
than we actually look, which is awesome.
- Yeah.
- But it's just been a great
experience here at K State.
The whole community
whether it be students
coming to get a cheap meal
or just families walking down the street
they've all really embraced us.
We definitely feel like we're excited.
Maybe want to expand the
operations, maybe do a food truck.
- Yeah.
- Something like that.
But for the time being
we're having a really good time
just embracing the community
and making lots of of good pasta.
- Yeah
- That is so-
I love the the pasta,
like the food truck idea.
But it is incredibly awesome and funny
that you just serve it
right out your window.
Like that's incredible. I love that.
The Pasta Boys and Girl were
kind enough to send me a plate.
So I'm trying it.
Here we go.
I love my job.
I get paid to eat y'all.
This is incredible.
Hold on.
This is hard to do.
And look, you know, classy.
Whatever, screw it.
(muffled) This is so good!
(audience cheering)
Santino, Quinn, Kennedy and Tyler
I'm liking your post right
now while cleaning my teeth.
Y'all, that's not all.
Our season long partner
pilot pen makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate student
entrepreneurs just like you.
So they're putting a thousand
dollars in your tip jar.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
(students cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you, Kelly.
Congratulations on being a success guys.
Keep it up.
Thank you.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Craig Robinson, Moose Weekes
Zeus McClurkin, Quinta
Brunson, Shirley Ralph,
Lisa Ann Walter, Nancy Lorraine,
Carolyn Clifford, Simon Shacket
and all our friends at W X
Y Z, Channel Seven Detroit.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
try some pasta.